[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey guys welcome to Fandango indie movie
guide I'm Alicia Malone and there are so
many great little films out this week in
theaters and at home so let's get
through them really quickly I want to
start with the documentary called
Dolores this is an in-depth look at one
of the most important activists and
feminists and also someone that a lot of
people haven't even heard about
including myself Dolores Huerta
she's a civil rights hero she's the
first general that I followed into she's
not afraid to speak truth to power
Dolores came up with the slogan si se
puede
yes we can she was right alongside Cesar
Chavez protesting for the rights of
workers and she was also a mother to
eleven children this documentary is
directed by Peter Bratt and it mixes
together archival footage with some
incredible interviews talking about how
important Dolores has been it also
doesn't shy away at looking at the
drawbacks of having a mother as an
activist she would frequently leave her
children at home to go and fight for
families of other people I left a couple
of my children behind that's part of the
sacrifice that we made and that we had
to make and it still pains me when I
think about it and it also looks at the
extra fight she had just by being a
woman in the activist space it is
fascinating inspiring and enlightening
Dolores is coming out in theaters from
this Friday we're knee-deep in sexism
when it comes to why she isn't study and
why people don't you know latina girls
need to see statues of you we have you
set the record straight
I mean women cannot be written out of
history
to accompany now to rectify Lake Bell
called I do until I don't my new project
will propose love is not sustainable
will you accept that marriage is dead
this is an ensemble movie which looks at
different types of relationships and
marriages it's all about a British
documentarian who enlists a bunch of
people in relationships to try to prove
her theory that marriage is dead
there's a two section almost two sexes
just so you know you do look mentally
challenged well that's fine because you
know what happy married to you is
challenging in so many ways off the
bunch the strongest pairing is Mary
Steenburgen and Paul Reiser they are
fantastic together the whole film is a
little bit hit and miss but overall it's
held together by the charm and grace of
its star Lake Bell who is turning into a
fantastic director I really enjoyed her
debut in a well and I'm so glad that
she's got I do until I don't coming to
theaters this Friday
you're all gonna do it we don't mean by
sex no no one's talking about sex you're
the only one who brought sex into it
it's not
speaking of great directors the
legendary Darden brothers who did two
days one night have another film coming
out called
the unknown girl this stars Adele hi
Nell as Jenny who is a young doctor who
one night when she's working alone in a
clinic decides not to answer the door
buzzer because it's late at night and
then she learns that the lady who was
ringing her doorbell was actually
murdered straight afterwards she knows
she'll feel really stupid when Professor
111 what kind of immersion see we're
gonna see something was born a port is
fine Jenny becomes obsessed in finding
out who this girl was and why she was
killed and who the killer might be it
all plays out like a murder mystery and
it isn't as strong as the previous
dead-end Brothers films but it is a
fascinating intriguing tale it only
doesn't live up to their standards
because they've set very very high
standards
well she does it with a limited so
charitable met such difficulties emotion
so I'm fairly do capital Darius okay
let's all severely I'm M Tom so
perfectly dairy trade also out in
limited theaters is rebel in the Rye
starring Nicholas Hoult as JD Salinger
so where we do know you're a writer what
do you think you do not write another
story and then another one after that
how is writing a real professional I
don't know if I'm cut out for this maybe
not this is written and directed by
Danny strong and it's a biopic of the
famously reclusive author who wrote The
Catcher in the Rye and also details his
relationship with a socialite who's
played by Zoe Dutch erased short stories
have been published I think Holden
Caulfield is a novel no I couldn't write
a whole novel Holden Caulfield deserves
an entire book this is a really solid
movie with great performances all around
it's shot perfectly the only fault is
that it's very conventional and that
feels like somewhat of a shame for such
an unconventional author but he did have
a very interesting story and it'll make
you want to go and read The Catcher in
the Rye once again pages at this book
with me when I stitch is it Normandy I
don't think it'd be alive if it wasn't
for this pocket
now to what you can watch at home and
there are two movies available on
Fandango now that I particularly
recommend the first is it comes at night
by Trey Edward Schultz miss stars Joel
Edgerton as the father of a family
living in a world where everybody has
been sick
there's not many survivors it's him his
wife and his son who has a lot of
interesting dreams then a family comes
to them and they have to figure out what
the family wants are they genuine in
needing help or is there something more
going on and welcome thank you very much
[Music]
if you miss this one at sceeto's
definitely don't miss it at home I love
the style it is creepy and I'll just
leave you feeling quite unsettled
the other film on Fandango now is my
cousin Rachel which features a fantastic
performance by Rachel vice whatever it
costs my cousin the pain and suffering
before he died I will return with full
measure upon the woman almost dead it is
a dark gothic thriller with a bit of
romance thrown in there also comments a
lot on being a woman in the 19th century
[Music]
it's very mysterious with a lot of
layers to delve into directed by Roger
Michele who also did Notting Hill
check out my cousin Rachel on Fandango
now I've been worried about you it's a
headache
the sickness this is a special batch
made it down straight you can lose
everything everything and last but not
least band aid is coming to home
entertainment this is written and
directed and starring Zoe lister-jones
alongside Adam pally
these two play a married couple we
figure out that the best way to resolve
their fights is through song a single
list our top 10 fights of all dishes is
big they think you can be a little
judgmental
you being lazy okay you're uptight
[Music]
also stars fred armisen as a quirky
neighbor this sells some truths about
relationships
checkout band-aid if you want a really
fun romantic movie to watch at home this
weekend
yeah like Renaissance Faire
that's in Rancho that's a sweet by it's
a Tom Petty by if you're looking for an
interesting indie film in theaters
I recommend Dolores I do until I don't
the unknown girl or rebel in the Rye and
at home you can catch it comes at night
my cousin Rachel or band-aid let me know
what you've been watching in the
comments below or on Twitter at Alicia
Malone and I'll see you next week bye
[Music]